YURI GRINSHTEYN: We should aim
to reduce toil via automation
whenever possible.
Today, I want to show you
how to automate the creation
of monitoring dashboards.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
While dashboards are
not a replacement
for well-defined SLOs,
alerting, or good observability,
they're widely used
by many involved
in service reliability.
And they are a
must-have capability
in any monitoring setup.
The first question you should
ask when setting up a dashboard
is, what should be
on the dashboard?
Thankfully, the answer to
that has been well documented
in the monitoring distributed
systems chapter in the SRE
book.
If you have nothing else,
start with the golden signals--
traffic, errors,
latency, and saturation.
I'll go over each one.
Let's take the
services running in GKE
and managed by the Istio
service mesh as an example.
We've covered using
Istio with Cloud
Monitoring and the
excellent telemetry
it provides in the past.
Today, we're going
to focus on using
some of the key metrics it
provides about traffic, errors,
and latency for our service.
Here's an example dashboard
showing all three.
The first golden signal is
traffic, essentially a measure
of how much user activity
the service is responding to.
Thankfully, Istio
provides this natively
for every service in the mesh.
The metric is called
Server Request Count.
And the first chart
in my dashboard,
request rates by service,
users that metric
and groups the results by the
destination service name label.
The next chart,
errors by service,
uses the same metric
and grouping options.
The only difference is
that the data is then
filtered to only count requests
where the response code is not
200.
Note that this is
a rough approach,
as it does include about 300
redirects and 400 errors, which
are often the result of
misconfigured or misbehaving
clients.
The last chart, again,
uses an Istio metric.
This time it's Server
Responsive Latencies, grouped
by destination_service_name
and using the 99th percentile
aggregation.
I'm not filtering out
errors for this one,
though it might be
a good idea if you
want to better understand how
long it takes to return errors
and successes separately.
Creating such a
dashboard manually
is not difficult, assuming
that the data is available.
But it is toil that should
be automated if possible.
With the release of the
dashboard's API, it now is.
You can also use the
API to, for example,
copy dashboards
between workspaces
to create additional
standardization via automation.
Let's take a look into how
we can use the API to create
this dashboard.
The general idea is
pretty straightforward.
We simply call the
projects.dashboards.create
method, passing a
dashboard's object, which
contains a name, description,
and a set of widget objects
that specify the
charts themselves.
Here's the JSON definition
for the Request Rates chart.
We'll put the links
to the blog post
where you can see
the details below.
I created this
manually, but you can
use the API Explorer to
create your own baseline
and simply populate
it with parameters.
Note that the filter specifies
the resource and metric.
This is also where
you would specify,
for example, the cluster
name, service name,
or other attributes if needed.
I use the default aligner
and the sum reducer
to simply total up the
requests and group them
by the destination_service_name
metric label.
To create the
dashboard itself, we
specified it as a grid
layout with the number
of columns we want and then
define the charts as widgets.
We then pass this in the body
of the request to the API.
And here we are.
Our dashboard is created
and ready to use.
We're working on the features to
make the API even more useful,
including enabling through
the G Cloud command line.
Also, contributors are
discussing and planning
the terraform module for
the monitoring dashboard API
in GitHub.
But you can and should
get started with dashboard
automation today.
Thanks for watching.
Come back next time.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]